Vì dân cả từ ngày 1,5 mồ tính mồ tính mồ tính thái gình vô trạm hiểu sấu, cán trên trọt huy bất động sản, thực hiện có trễ thứ 2, tự nồng thuế vẫn phải thực hiện một số gí buộc hành chính.
Gồm thông báo dành tu tự hật động cho tuy bất động sản trong năm, và thông báo số tại quản lưng hàng, học viết định từ sự dụng cho hật động kích giói.
Thác cuộc tuế đã tạo thật lời trong người luật thuế cán trên đưa trọn tần xuất thông báo dành tu vùa hợp bấy tình hiểu thực tế,
của thẻ người cho tuy bất động sản của thẻ người sọn thuộc báo dành tu mồ t立 lần cho cán năm tính thái, bối thời hạn chậm nhất là ngày 3 mồ tính mồ tính mồ tính của năm dự lịch tiếp theo.
Chứ khởi vì người sọn thuộc báo dành tuy hai lần trong năm, thời hạn người thuộc báo lần tính nhất chậm nhất và ngày 3 mồ tính mồ tính mồ tính mồ tính mồ tính thái.
Vì thuộc báo dành tuy được thực hiện hoàn toàn bằng tương tương diện tự, thông qua ứng dụng ý thách mồ bị phó kệ thống thông tin giải quyết thủ tục thành chíng tuy.
Lên quan đến việc thông báo số tại khoảng lần hàng hoặc viên tự,
cuộc tuyến cho biết nổi cán giân chỉ phải kê khai một lần trong sự hợp chưa tính thông báo thuộc tin tại khoảng.
Viên tự cho cuộc quan thuế hoặc thuộc tin này chưa được thẻ hiện trong hợp lòng cho thuế bất động sản.
Tây hạn thực hiện thông báo số tại khoảng lần hàng hoặc viên tự, nực áp dụng tương ứng với thẻ trong báo dịch thuộc tập quy định hiện hàng.